[Music]
for president biden has
said his number one priority since
coming into office is a nearly two
trillion dollar coronavirus
economic relief package now he's got his
wish
schuyler henry has more details from
capitol hill
the motion is adopted
[Applause]
democrats have passed president biden's
1.9 trillion dollar coronavirus relief
package
without republican support they were all
conceived in liberty and dedicated the
proposition that we are
equal but in this body
it seems as though only one can have a
voice one of the republicans inside this
house
unanimously apparently opposed this bill
by some 60 percent
of the republicans in america polled say
we're for this bill
included in the bill is an extension of
federal unemployment benefits at three
hundred dollars a week
money to help schools reopen increased
vaccine distribution
and support for state and local
governments it also includes a tax
credit of up to thirty six hundred
dollars per child
the expansions in this bill are
estimated to cut child
poverty in half well who's going to end
up paying back
that 5 500 dollars per person is going
to be the very children
that we are professing to help and there
will be a new round of stimulus checks
fourteen hundred dollars for individuals
making seventy five thousand dollars a
year
or less and twenty eight hundred dollars
for couples making less than one hundred
fifty thousand dollars those will start
going out this month
president biden will be able to sign the
bill into law
this week as the nation marks the one
year anniversary of the global pandemic
and shutdowns across the country i can
announce that the president will sign
the bill
at the white house on friday afternoon
the immediate focus is on
increasing vaccine distribution to reach
as many people as possible
today we're averaging above 2 million
shots per day
the biden administration is purchasing
100 million more doses of the johnson
and john